yeah cool let's do it one more time
let's go
why because we
love making movies
it's hard work to go to that blank piece
of paper and start
from square ones start from scratch
every single solitary time i want to
make movies
that people will watch them and that
will make them want to make movies
and i kept thinking about it and i kept
thinking about it
this is my time to do movies let me try
one more time
to make it a movie let me try one more
time and that was the move it's like the
suspense is a rubber band
and i'm just stretching it and
stretching it and stretching and see how
far it can stretch
as long as that rubber band can stretch
the longer the scene can hold the more
suspenseful it is
so you want to just stretch it until the
rubber band breaks
before i settle in on what i'm going to
do i'm contemplating a lot of different
things oh there's that book that i've
always wanted to turn into
a movie maybe i'd start reading that
again and
go over my old notes uh uh
i i explore some different ideas you
know see what stage and the incubator
that they are at any given time
especially when i'm looking for
inspiration
you know it's almost a metaphor for
falling in love you date a lot of people
and you flirt with a lot of people and
everything is going great
um but then you meet the right one and
once you once once i realized that
oh okay uh this is grab me
and oh this this is genuinely legit
and now maybe i'm thinking about music
choices for it and trying to find
different music choices for it and web
spinning about it and
maybe it gets me to actually start
writing a little bit and
pretty shortly into that process i'll
probably end up writing something that's
like
okay i'm doing this uh when i started it
years ago
and started writing it years ago i had a
different storyline
and the reason i couldn't really finish
it years ago was because that storyline
was just
too big it just wasn't a movie it was it
could have been a 12 hour mini series
but it wasn't a movie and i remember
thinking man
what i'm too big for movies you know and
so i
put it away and so when i came back to
it and i really wanted to actually make
it a movie
i realized what i would have to do is is
come up with a new story i'd come up
with all the characters and i came up
with the idea of the bastards themselves
and that's where i came up with the idea
of the german soldier frederick zoller
who had killed all these people was a
huge hero in germany and they make a
movie about his life
and the bastard's job is to blow up the
premiere of that movie
after jackie brown i put kill bill off
to the side
and i started writing glorious bastards
and that became this never ending
process because
people thought i was going through
writer's block you know i was going
through the opposite i couldn't stop
writing i'd have a 100-page script
and no end in sight so i was trying to
keep taming it and i couldn't
great material you know like that
opening scene i wrote that that was the
first thing i ever wrote
[Applause]
my id at the time because it was just so
big and so unwieldy
was to do it as a mini-series and that
really was what i was planning on doing
and uh you've written a lot from that
yeah i mean that's a hell of a lot of
writing though i'd have to be doing for
like a six
hour mini series then i'm right i'm like
the day before the day almost
i'm getting ready to start that hard
work and luke bason was in town then we
went out to dinner me and him and his
producer partner
and i'm telling him about my big mini
series and glorious bastards i'm gonna
do and the producer guy
is just like oh yeah look that sounds
awesome that's a
that's that's the way to do it quentin
that's the way to do it
it looks like yeah i don't know i don't
know this is french
well what what what's the matter i don't
know i mean
you know you are one of the
few filmmakers left out there that makes
me want to leave my house
and go to a cinema and sit in the cinema
and watch it on the screen
anybody else like uh watch the dvd i can
see it on tv it'd be fine i'm i'm good
but mo you know you make me want to
leave the house and go see cinema
and now you tell me i'm going to have to
wait four years
five years before i can do that again
i'm sorry i'm not so excited
oh funny and you know
every once in a while somebody tells you
something somebody says something to you
that you can never unhear right
and once he said that i couldn't unhear
it
and i kept thinking about it and i kept
thinking about it and i kept thinking
about it
this is my time to do movies let me try
one more time
to make it a movie don't just throw up
my hands and say i give up
and make this incredibly sprawling epic
let me try
one more time
and that was the movie
um now the thing about it is if
one wants to think of this movie as a
fairy tale
or a fantasia you're welcome to feel
feel free that's not really exactly
where i'm coming from on it
um where i'm coming from is this in
the course of my story my characters
change the course of the war now that
didn't happen because my characters
didn't exist
but if they had have existed everything
that happens
is fairly plausible 99999 oh yes yes yes
yes
if there had been a frederick zoller who
did what he did
at that time in the war i'm sure garbles
would have made a movie about him
the way uh america made a movie about
audie murphy
and if frederick zoller looked like
daniel bruhl and was this charming then
he could have been cast as the lead
and then they could very well have had a
big premiere and
so on and so on and so on colonel hans
landa played by christoph waltz and
his nickname that the jews have given
him in france is the jew hunter
yeah and and talk about the acting in a
minute
how did you create the character what
was it based on or was that simply out
of your mind
it's you know he just just flowed out of
me i mean i really
can't really tell you well i did this or
i did that i st you know i think the
first scene that i wrote in the movie
was the opening scene i always have to
kind of write an order
uh the opening scene in the film where
he's interrogating the
french farmer at the film but then you
believe then that that character is
fully formed in your mind because
the dialogue that takes place the
mannerisms that take place continue
through the film in every encounter he
has he's not
really fully formed i mean he they grow
they they teach me
who they are like to give you an example
uh
uh one of the things about his character
that's one of the most striking things
is he's obviously a linguistic genius
well i didn't know that when i wrote
that first scene i knew he could speak
french
but i didn't know that he was such a
linguistic genius until
he just kept being able to speak one
language after another
then did you have to find an actor who
could do that oh yeah that was
the thing that was the big deal i mean
one of the things when i finished that
script
i knew that colonel londa was uh one of
the greatest characters i've ever
written one of the greatest characters i
will ever write
first of all he's larger than life in
some way
or he has mannerisms that are defining
or he has a style
well you know i guess it's more there's
a look he has well i think it's you know
i mean i've been doing this for like 17
years now so i do have a little rogues
gallery of characters that are like my
characters
and he was just one of the strongest
that ever
that that ever had ever come out and
then maybe in some way
he revealed himself more to me as far as
like i really
let the character live so i was really i
discovered him as i was writing him
what's interesting about him is that he
does everything with drama
yeah every set piece is a dramatic piece
whether it is because he discovered a
shoe at a scene of a massacre yeah
and he knows where to go find the person
who the shoe belongs to
rather than just saying is this your
shoe yeah as an elaborate ritual oh yeah
well that's the thing is but you know
everything london does
i mean i mean he is a detective that's
first and foremost where he's coming
from he's a detective
and everything he does his scenes are
basically almost all interrogation
scenes at the moment he says that it's
somewhere in the beginning that's it
yeah
and um and everything he does is some
version of an interrogation and every
piece of interrogation
is uh a piece of theater or or or a
mind game with the participant i'll just
give you an example
and it was also it helps describe how me
and christoph worked on the film
just to give you an idea um in the
script uh
in the opening scene when he's
interrogating this french farmer
it's the french farmer takes out a pipe
and starts smoking it and at some point
linda says hey can i take out my pipe
and he goes yes and he pulls out this
big giant calabash you know which is the
pipe that sherlock holmes smokes and
it's a very funny moment
and when it happens and he drinks milk
yeah and he takes the farmers
he's a dairy farmer so he drinks his
milk as opposed to wine but he has this
pipe
and uh so i wrote that in the script and
then i actually had a couple of more
moments where i had
wanda take out the pipe and like you
know smoke and
and so it was obvious it was london's
pipe but
i started thinking about it more and
more as pre-production was going on and
i had dinner with kristoff
and i asked him i go let me ask you a
question in the scriptures
you know it implies that this is
definitely lawn this pipe and he uses it
to think
but let me ask you a question what if
wanda
doesn't smoke a pipe he knows the farmer
smokes a pipe and so at a certain point
he brings out this pipe and what pipe
does he bring out he brings out the
sherlock holmes pipe
one you can say it's a sexual thing
because my pipe's bigger than yours
all right and the other thing you can
say i know you're lying and i got you
i've got the sherlock holmes pipe
you know so maybe he doesn't smoke a
pipe at all it's simply just an
interrogation technique to throw the
farmer uh you know send him more to hell
and like so what do you think kristoff
because no he doesn't smoke a pipe at
all it is simply
an active theater and shashana in the
film is
um a jewish woman who a jewish young
girl
who saw her family massacred by the the
nazis and she's been hiding in in paris
and uh the thing is with shashana
years ago when i wrote the character uh
i had her
much much more of like being a real
badass
and uh she was killing nazis and she had
a list of officers she was like a real
joan of arc of the jews and
you know she'd snipe nazis from the
rooftops of paris and all this kind of
stuff i like this
and it was it was a lot of fun all right
and i wrote these really great action
sequences for shashana and that's that
was the deal
so why didn't we use them well because i
put it away
and i did kill bill and almost
everything that i liked about shashana i
gave to the bride
and so the bride did all that stuff and
the bride's the one with a list and the
bride's the one going down the list
and and kicking butt so uh when i come
back to it
after kill bill i go well i can't do
this again but what i liked about
that aspect was it actually enabled me
to make shashana more realistic
as opposed to being this tough jonah of
our girl she's just she's a survivor
she's a survivor it actually made her
much more like jackie brown
than the bride because i think
shoshanna's strength is
keeping it together in tight situations
where anyone else would crumble when
anyone else would melt
she manages to keep her poise what do
you call it when you create a backstory
for an actor yeah exactly yeah
you create a backstory for an actor and
uh for the character that's one of my
things whether or not the audience knows
about it i know
about the character's past and i just
want the actors to know now the audience
doesn't need to know like for instance
uh brad pitt's character although
lorraine has a rope burn
exactly around his neck but i never want
to explain what i desperately wanted to
know well i want you to just figure it
out all right i mean that's up to you
to to supply where that rope burn came
from i mean i would love to have had
a little bit of a conversation that he
would have referred to that
yes i i i wanted you to know i would
have told you i like the idea
but your idea of cinema then is it keep
a lot of stuff in you want mystery
in the film itself you know it's like
you want us not to know everything well
i like the idea
i like the idea that if okay if you
contemplate why there is a rope burn
there
and somebody else contemplates whether
it's a roper and there and somebody else
contemplates it and three different
people come up with three different
uh reasons why he got a roper and those
are three different movies you all saw
and i like that idea i like the idea
that you open up the briefcase in pulp
fiction and i don't tell you what's in
there
but it's up to you to figure out what's
in there and now that's your
movie and you'll make that decision
somewhere down the line now if i tell
you at this table what it is then you'll
throw that away and i don't want you to
throw away that's your movie that's a
scene that's built around both dialogue
but
dialogue as a mechanism for suspense
and i remember after i came out with uh
pulp fiction so i had two movies by that
time
uh some critic said something to the
effect of tarantino will never be a
master of suspense because he's too
far in love with minutia and i actually
thought that was a fair enough criticism
back then
so in now i want to actually do a movie
where i actually
indulge in suspense and i go for it and
my method of it
and use that scene in the opening scene
of the movie as an example
it's like um it's like there's there's
the scene above ground
and the scene below ground and the scene
above ground is what's going on and the
dialogue and them sitting around this
table and talking
underneath it it's like the suspense is
a rubber band
and i'm just stretching it and
stretching it and stretching and see how
far it can stretch
now normally in a situation when you do
a movie you try to make your scenes as
compact as possible so there's not air
and you don't wear out you're welcome
with the audience
but under this method as long as that
rubber band can stretch
the longer the scene can hold the more
suspenseful it is
that scene is more suspenseful at 22
minutes and would be at eight
so you want to just stretch it until the
rubber band breaks when it's working
it's a lot easier because you know it's
working it's you're you're
you're inspired uh you know one
character
character a says this then character b
says that and character c
says that and all of a sudden and
character c just told you something you
didn't know
and now you have to work from that of
either the characters
in the scene have to work from that new
information but now you're also having
to work from that new
information now i can tend to go long
when i
do that and so i have to be
really aware of like
okay is this holding up
can this be this
long you know and um
i mean i mean hands down there's no
other there's
there's no example to the extent that
the
the basement sequence right the opening
well not the openings i'm sorry
okay opening scene yeah the opening
scene held either
questions okay it might be too long for
other people but it definitely wasn't
too long for me
the basement scene but the basement
scene in glorious bastards
deep in the movie yes i mean deep in the
[ __ ] movie
and there's no aldo there's no shashana
there's nobody you know
a bunch of [ __ ] you just met
and now all of a sudden they're in a
40-minute scene
that's supposed to be suspenseful it
absolutely is
in a different language for an american
movie
and you know i just i had
i was never my intention for that to be
that long
i just started writing it and it kept
holding
it kept holding they kept talking i kept
keeping the reality of the situation if
they could be exposed at any moment
i'd almost exposed them that it seemed
like they got away with it then
something else would happen
and and the thing is if you think
it's long when you look at it imagine
when i'm writing it
because i guarantee you it's longer in
my script version
all right after i get through editing it
all right it's actually longer
but not only is it longer i'm writing it
by hand so every one
every two pages is every two handwritten
pages is one
script writing page so the stack is
getting crazy high
and my page number is not 40 pages it's
80 pages in handwritten script
and i'm like holy [ __ ] [ __ ]
um and then i'd
go over it again and like i i like it
i i think it holds you know and dare i
say i think it makes it more suspenseful
i think the longer
i can stretch this rubber band out and
actually feel that there's more rubber
there to give
the more suspenseful it it will be now
once the script's finished and i put it
all together then i'm not really worried
about it anymore
i figure it's worked but when i'm
writing it and it's
got it's getting to be that much and
like i said
never seems like 40 to me it seems like
80 pages to me
and but uh i just i
i i i trust i trust i trust myself
why do you write in longhand i can't
write poetry on a computer mate
you know
yes i can definitely always surprise
myself in fact if i don't surprise
myself
then that's kind of the time to hang it
up and one of the reasons i'm kind of
able to do that is um
is it's not like i have to kind of write
for a living it's not like i'm a
professional screenwriter there always
is this aspect that i'm
having to remember how it is i do what i
do
it always just has to start little by
little coming back to me
oh yeah that's how i do it oh yeah
that's the process
and i think that's the thing that keeps
it keeps it fresh because
everything is always square one every
single solitary time i start a new
cool let's thing it one more time let's
go why
because we love making
movies
well i mean i mean we'll look just for
instance i mean one of the most talented
filmmakers of uh
you know my generation is david fincher
right all right but he's not in the same
category as me because i'm a writer
director and
that makes it different that makes it a
different thing you know and i think one
of the things
is um it's hard work to go to that blank
piece of paper and start
from square ones start from scratch
every single solitary time you are at
the bottom of mount
everest every single solitary time and
everything you've done before
not only does not help you it could even
like hang over your head
and that is a tough road to hoe and you
make less movies that way
and it's a lot easier to go and look at
the scripts that are out there and
available and you can maybe work with a
writer or do a little rewrite or do that
kind of thing and you get more movies
made
but you know cut to six years down the
line and where's that voice
it's gone away and i'm proud of the fact
that with the exception of jack i mean i
love jackie brown but i don't really
have any intention of doing any more
novel things never say never but i don't
know
nobody you're not going to adopt anybody
else's novel no i mean i don't see that
happening right now
because to me the glory and what i do
is the fact that it starts with a blank
piece of paper you look at something
like glorious bastards and that did not
if my mother never met my father that
would not exist in any way shape or form
if my mother hadn't met my father there
would be no and glorious bastards in any
way it started off with
a pen and a piece of paper and now i
have always if you weren't born there
would be no english masters
you